all right Democrats have reached I think
the obvious conclusion that their only
path sure path to victory is the burn it
all down approach of the neo Bolsheviks
on the streets Joe Biden's team has
formed common cause with those who not
only seek the destruction of the nuclear
family if you don't believe me check out
BLM's website they've actually decided
that promoting racial hatred is the only
way they can win
they know that Trump's policies it's
obvious have delivered results for
working people of all races while theirs
have largely failed
now the left hopes that by inflaming
racial division and hiding their
candidate they could avoid a real debate
on the issues so over the weekend the
president responded with two powerful
speeches to celebrate our independence
and identify the domestic forces now
threatening it his remarks at Mount
Rushmore reaffirmed America's identity
and inspired millions of Americans
who've basically been living in despair
because of the one-two punch of the
virus and the continuing riots these
radicals would tear down the very
heritage for which men gave their lives
to win the civil war there were tear
down the principles that propelled the
abolition of slavery and ultimately
around the world ending an evil
institution that had plagued humanity
for thousands and thousands of years our
opponents would tear apart the very
documents that Martin Luther King used
to express his dream they would tear
down the beliefs culture and identity
that have made America the most vibrant
and tolerant society in the history of
the earth we will proclaim the ideals of
the Declaration of Independence and we
will never surrender the spirit and the
courage and the cause of July 4th 1776
upon this ground we will stand for
and unwavering in the face of lies meant
to divide us demoralize us and diminish
us now you can always tell how effective
one of the president's speeches is by
how friendly frenzied the reaction from
liberals I actually thought it was some
fantasy he's just desperate there was a
lot about history about God and our
great country much of it very ominous
there was no attempt here to unify the
country it was a divisive message the
president threw down the cultural wall
gotten it in defense of dead white men
lavatory faithful watching it you
realize how disturbed and how disturbing
this president really is you notice I
described liberals and Kasich and
Jennifer Rubin are among them you bet
now if wine was an Olympic sport these
folks would be draped in gold medals in
moments of rare candor they know that
Trump beats Biden hands down on jobs and
wages for african-americans Trump beats
Biden on education he favours liberation
for parents and students who are stuck
in bad schools Trump beat Biden on
prison reform Obama and Biden both
talked a good game they didn't get it
done and of course Trump has done
something that by never did he is
actually hired and promoted
african-americans and other minorities
across as many businesses now where
Biden and Democrats are content to
patronize african-americans with these
meaningless symbolic gestures
conservatives actually believe that
minorities what would all people want a
fair chance at prosperity and to pursue
their happiness in freedom and safety
Trump knows this is only possible with a
vibrant growing economy where all
criminals are prosecuted meanwhile Biden
thinks he can surf to victory on racial
anger stoked by mobs many of whom are
white who would rather see every city in
America burn than a second Trump term
now this requires a massive
effort to lie and defame one that an
honest press would have exposed long ago
now as I said before instead of covering
the Democrats the media cover for them
their tactics and their toxic
associations I'm talking about so long
as the end game of any activist or
politician is to rid America of Trump oh
the press will excuse all manner of
falsehoods hypocrisy and even
criminality
so to stoke racial tension the Biden
campaign requires a massive effort to
lie and defame one that of course would
have already been exposed long ago now
when you think back when you think about
how this whole thing went down how did
it go down it went down after this long
shutdown people had a lot of time on
their hands
again if we continue to allow these lies
and this ongoing slander and defamation
to continue well what happens people
will continue to lose faith in the
system of laws and even and equal
protection you know people
looters got a bad name during the you
know George Floyd protests but thank
goodness for the looters man you have a
place called Target you have a store
called Target you're gonna be a target
you know these places have absolutely
contributed to the oppression now the
left is even trying to get the Broadway
sensation Hamilton canceled if you think
that's wacky it is that's right there is
a cancel Hamilton hashtag out there now
never mind that all the key roles
including those of Alexander Hamilton
and George Washington are played by
people of color in the musical critics
say it glosses over key facts they claim
Hamilton was not an abolitionist and
traded slaves for his in-laws the mere
fact that it celebrates the founding era
in any positive way to good music is
ample reason for the left to call for
its cancellation now the only thing at
this point that's sacred to them is the
notion that if you're a leftist
you cannot be questioned or prosecuted
for crimes yeah ends justify the means
you bet they do
past grievances mean never having to say
you're sorry the media will give you a
pass for anything at the same time they
spy racism around every corner
Smollett says he was assaulted by two
masked men who yelled out racial and
homophobic slurs police are
investigating the incident as a possible
hate crime a horrifying racist incident
heinous heinous ugly crude cowardly way
hate crime NASCAR is investigating a
horrible incident a noose was found in
the garage stall of Bubba Wallace much
as NASCAR may try to distance itself
from that it's a living breathing part
of their sport oh and then when Trump
calls him on it albeit via an artfully
worded tweet he becomes the target do
you believe the President sees racism as
a potential path to re-election look
there's no doubt that and I've said this
before this president his political
calculus is all about division not
addition and why does the Left do all
this well simple to deflect from the
Democrats own horrific record on race
the economy and crime this is now a
third week in a row where we have seen
children shot and killed here as part of
a weekend where we saw more than 60
people shot and over a dozen people
killed it so just blank what is
happening right now the ecosystem of
Public Safety that isn't just law
enforcement but as local community base
they too have really been hit hard by
kovat and are now just kind of coming
back online and getting their footing
what here's here that Chicago scene a
tragic level of violence since the black
lives matter marches started and it's
claiming African American lives and
costing the black community dearly the
bad guys here aren't the folks going to
Mount Rushmore they're criminal
murdering children on the streets of our
nation's third-largest city 80 people
were shot and 17 killed in Chicago last
week week weekend alone in at least 13
of those were african-american and it
gets even more tragic including among
the dead as a seven year old Natalia
Wallace she was shot in the head she was
visiting her grandmother for the fourth
of July and sadly she wasn't the only
child killed in Southeast DC eleven
year-old Devon McNeil shot and killed at
a fourth of July cookout with his family
armed thugs in Atlanta murdered
eight-year-old Sakura Turner near the
Wendy is where Rashard Brooks died at
the hands of police now this is
senseless and awful killing and it's
obviously left her parents heartbroken
shattered and asking why they killed
your home get your own it's because of
burial they killed my baby because she
crossed the barrier Amanda you tell you
killed a child she do not to nobody
now every single one of these cities is
run by Democrats and rather than
addressing violent crime drugs and
fatherlessness plaguing so many
communities they just make excuses they
throw out phrases like systemic racism
unconscious bias or white privilege and
minimizing the importance of personal
responsibility love of one's neighbor
and the value of every human life so
rather than insisting on law and order
safety in every community including
african-american communities this is the
best they can offer we talk about
systemic racism and the trauma in the
anxiety and we think about the
leadership or the lack thereof that we
have coming from the highest office in
the land I think that you are seeing so
many emotions play out and and so too
often it's playing out and violence in
our streets
emotions are playing out I think some
folks are still trying
to pretend that all of this mayhem will
stop if we just let the Democrats have
the White House well we have the
Democrats in power in Atlanta and
Chicago in New York in Baltimore and
Beyond and beyond what's happened
so this thinking is foolish and naive
the Democrats have shown their utterly
unwilling to restrain the hard left from
seizing property and committing violence
and that's for the culture wars why
would the radicals stop when they think
they're winning so ignore the folks who
say that it just gets better when we let
the Democrats have more power the only
way this situation gets better is for
Democrats to lose and lose so often that
they're forced to apologize for their
relentless slandering of our nation's
history and by extension the majority of
our citizens who still unapologetically
love this country and still believe that
it's worth celebrating and that's the
angle